my name is Yaniv I'm coming from Far
Israel I'm on the line between New York
and Israel but this time I came directly
from Israel so it was an interesting
Journey
um yeah pretty long not recommend
um
well I'm from Memphis for those of you
who don't know us yet we are a Next
Generation event processing platform so
basically
a very intelligent message broker with
the day two operations that allows you
to build
real-time pipelines or streaming
pipelines really really fast on top of
Memphis Bulger
um and yeah so
govern your data client so it can be a
lot of things
um in when we
when we say data governance but in this
talk I will concentrate specifically on
schemas and structures
um so let's let's start
so I'm using uh I'm using the term data
clients a lot in my session so just to
create a baseline what are data clients
and what does it mean so
basically data clients are everything
that all the data producers all the data
consumers that consume or produce data
within our data platform or Federated
data data platform within our
organization so every black circle can
be a potential data client so Pinot CRM
predictions maybe spark a billing
service now the challenges doesn't
derive from the amount of data clients
that we have in terms of structures and
schemas but usually it comes from the
complexity of the single service so for
example if we have a certain CRM they
probably won't do any adjustments to us
they will expect you to send or push
data in a certain way in a certain
structure that they expect you to uh to
to provide them and we also have the the
collectors on the side so some Services
some data clients that consume or
produce data and ingest data into our
data platform so it usually looks like
that spaghetti
can be a lot more can be a lot less
and other another type of architecture
with a bunch of data clients and and
moving Parts can be like the metal
architecture three-tier architecture as
you can see structures
are modified across the different
checkpoints
and yeah so getting data from point A to
point Z
that can be a challenging thing
definitely when we have different stages
along the way
um yeah so
so with that context of data clients
come streaming pipelines
um I would say the concept of streaming
pipelines came from the idea that we
need to be more decoupled so we would be
able to
maybe change certain stages or have more
control over the stages or the structure
of the data as it flows between point A
to point Z so usually we would have like
if we have the source on the left and
the destination on the right in the
middle we would have some services that
uh control the the pre-processing of the
data the enrichment the extraction the
transformation
and I'm pretty sure you're all familiar
with
um changing the upstream or changing
structure as it flows between A to Z
because all of a sudden we have a
destination that requires different keys
or different fields or different
structure or different format
so pretty sure you can you can recognize
with that
um we never change the Upstream we
always add more keys more fields to our
schema
so it usually will looks like that and
the growth and the size of the schema
will grow exponentially in terms of size
and in terms of shape but we always
do our best not to break the backward
compatibility we always add
keys or or add more on top of the
initial structure that we that we build
the entire platform around it so
as you can see the size is growing and
well in good cases we get tons of waste
traffic higher costs and in this
economic environment I would say cost
became something that we all aware of
and we also get some drops
extra hops if statements are latency
when we want to change the structure of
the data and when we want to change the
the scheme of the data to be able to get
ingested by the different destinations
and in worst cases we get clients
crashes which means which brings me to
before getting to the solution and now I
propose to govern
um the data manipulation that you do
while the data is in motion between
sources to destination it gives it gets
me to like my own personal experience as
a data engineer in some big company in
Israel so Unexpected Journey of event
I know if if some of you relate to that
uh to that scenario but I call in the
middle of the night infrastructure looks
okay we have tons of observability tools
everything looks decent right but all of
a sudden like stripe service is not
consuming data so the company loses
money you're smiling so you probably had
one of those calls and messages get
redelivered dlqs exploding lags uh
please figure it out so yeah let's let's
figure it out
um that was like the usual
streaming pipeline that we had so
certain Getters certain collector of
events that push events or push messages
or data into a certain a certain queue a
certain topic and then we have a service
sorry tagging then we had a service from
a different team so it was a really
distributed architecture so every team
within the organization itself
was responsible for a different service
that did something within the pipeline
itself so in the middle of the night I
was responsible for the auditing and
tagging but all of a sudden like I need
to call for three different teams and
asking like what went wrong and why this
tribe service getting structures that it
doesn't know how to how to interpret and
how to analyze or how to consume so we
basically form up like a war room with
all the different team leads and we
started to follow the tracks of the
events and understand what changed the
the structure itself because we didn't
have any automatic governance system
that make sure that we're enforcing
schemas and nothing can pushed into into
the pipeline without
us being aware to
so like that's just a like a sample of
of the message that the striped service
um expect to receive so fairly simple
user ID tag date and and card number
um
so we started to dig in more and
research and understand like what are
the services that touches the data and
the events on the way to stripe
um and we found out that some
um super intelligent new team member
decided to build tagging V1 and do some
a b testing in production and push it
towards the the event so data comes in
from together into taking v0 but also to
taking V1 and taking V1 decided that he
wants to put the credit card
number within like an embed document of
credit card and that's something that
stripe service was not aware to and you
get weird phone calls in the middle of
the night
so uh yeah so how to avoid it
okay
so uh it was not nice and it happens a
lot it happens a lot to uh to our
customers as well
um because I think that enforcing schema
is not the easiest thing to do
definitely when you have already like a
solid data platform and that not using
schemas and every microservice has its
own uh structures and it has its own
like protophiles
um so all of a sudden do something like
that like a distributed governance
system or automatic system
um that's not the easiest thing to do
but
we can do something about it we can do
um something to enforce schemas and make
sure we don't get those phone calls in
the middle of the night so the first
thing would be to establish a central
pace for uh for our schema so instead of
every microservice to store its own uh
schema and then when something has
changed and we want to do an upstream
change or not an upstream change but
change the uh the ingested schema
entirely
um instead of going to each service
individually and if you're familiar with
the microservices architecture you
probably have like dozens of those so
it's not really scalable and so instead
of going to each micro service we have a
central place that stores all all of our
schemas the second thing would be
actually create a schema so I mean too
many organizations have void doing that
and I'm not really I mean I know what
does it mean to use like to enforce
schemas and to use schemas with the
current tool set and the current
landscape it can be hard but I mean it
can it can get you off like so many
potential errors so just create a schema
and then enforce it on top of your micro
services and how to do it with like
uh some open source tools so
um I'm familiar with several several
organizations just created like a git
monoreepo as the schema store so they
didn't want to use like a schema
registry
um or they're not using async and
they're not doing async communication or
message broker at all so they created a
git mono repo where they store all these
schemas and then
um and then we create like a broadcast
service that server that basically
publish all the changes within that repo
um super interesting concept it does
um get the job done
um a bit harder to to maintain but
um definitely definitely get you to
at least the first stage of enforcing
schemas and having a unified Plus for
those schemas
um
then make sure that every producer or
every data client
checks if there are updates because we
don't want it to be like a monolith that
doesn't change we want it to be
those changes to be broadcast to the uh
to the clients themselves and
that it will happen during run time so
if we will do some runtime checks within
our data clients it would be super easy
to enforce new schemas or enforce
changes
um last but not least I cannot say it
enough or explain it enough why it is so
important to use protoba for Avo you get
like immediate 30
less traffic or in terms of workload and
sizes use protobuf it's it's fairly easy
and and do a lot of it it will make your
CFO super happy so uh use protoba
forever
and educate your team members you cannot
avoid that one you need to do some
education and make sure that there is no
like a bright someone that try a b
testing in production and and put
something into your uh to your streaming
pipeline
um fairly fairly fast fairly simple it's
pretty late thank you very much I just
wanted to share a few a few tips with
that and thank you for being here
[Music]